[Music]
Irving needs more
okay good beer done hello everybody and
welcome back to more of surgeon a
simulator now the last time that I
played this I did not complete my goal
in operation so we have to go back today
and show those [ __ ] what we can do
and we will not stop and we will not
give up until we reach our goals so
let's just get right back into it and
play some games shall we alright let's
get into this and let's go hello sir
would you like a heart transplant by the
most handsome man in the entire world
alright let's see let's see let's see
here all right let's see all right let's
see all right let's see what do we do
here all right let's see Oh mr. Shaw oh
you're gonna oh you [ __ ] oh you
[ __ ]
oh you oh you're a real [ __ ] oh you
are you [ __ ] are you [ __ ] that oh
you [ __ ] [ __ ] alright we're just
gonna take this part put it there
pat pat mister you're on your way to a
better place a better place indeed nurse
[Music]
where's my scalpel nurse he's falling
off the face of the earth nurse he needs
your assistance why's there no one here
with me why am I in a drug-induced nurse
how do I get his ribs open nurse I can't
use any of these materials nurse he's
being a little bubbly bubbly [ __ ]
he's read a little thoughtfully bubbly
[ __ ] I saw a peaceful bubbly wobble
he's being a little [ __ ] Jim with his
father not revenge bad yes
even with my strong arms I cannot get
the saw to work on
man's chest mercy rates my heart he
makes my heart sad nurse in times like
this I like to be appreciative about
what I have because this man here he's
going to die but not me not today no I
will not die and I will not fail
so we have to save this man's life no
more drugs for me this is a drug-free
zone I am the perfect man
I've got no faults I've got all right we
got a hammer back now we just need to do
a little slapping just walking around
here oh don't be such a little man yeah
this shot y'all little it's with your
ribs going everywhere I can't get the I
can't get his ribs opening would you
like to learn about space I love space
if NASA came to me today and said we
want to shove a man into space we want
to shove a man right in the spaces anus
I'd be the first in line
no questions asked I'd leave everything
behind even chica and that's saying a
lot but it's proving how much I truly
love space look at this shirt what is
this shirt say look at this shirt look
at this look at it what does it say NASA
and if my arms if my arms want to go
into space I am then I am submiss man in
the world and if I want to go into space
I will it'll be my dream it'll be my
destiny and I will achieve my goals just
as we will achieve this surgery because
I'm not going to let this man down I am
going to use this man
a symbol of respect and a symbol of
space and I will be both in space and
respected yeah I know what I need I know
what I need
I've got my play button with me we
should be able to do this now sorry
sorry do you know who I am
Do You Know Who I am sir Waterloo don't
fix your bones that is a promise that is
a promise sir I will be committed I will
be committed to saving your life and
that is a markiplier promise every
single day I will be here protecting you
every single thing and if I don't only
90 ghost peppers
oh but chug an entire glass of pepper
juice sir sir sorry you with me are you
with me but markiplier
[Music]
my failed
I should be better we do because you're
here day after day and I know that you
all have so much respect and that's the
foundation of the chairs respect and I
know that I just haven't done enough but
I promise and I'll do more elite 40 50
60 ghost peppers a day to make sure that
I keep my class because I we didn't save
the man but we did have a good time
still handsome as ever I'm gonna leave
this here for today but we will be back
insistently tomorrow so thank you
everybody so much for watching and as
always I will see you in the next video
ba ba
[Music]